[Music]
[Music]
it's been about a week since we last saw
you
I'm Mike that's Mary quiche oh you
didn't do anything my name you just put
Mikey
some people call me Mike my family calls
me Mikey we're playing resin able to
remake we're what oh yeah
been a long day some like pocket of
thanks I'm the opposite of opposed oh
yeah no worries this has been well
there's a lot going on right like
there's a lot of games really saying
we're officially out of like the dry
season January is like kind of known for
more of like a chill time but now we're
like in it yeah like I'm playing Metro
apex legends just came out Monday X
legends really fun I can't say how good
Metro is yet playing warframe and what's
the last one
Oh anthem kind of getting ready for that
and crackdown I'm hoping crack that'll
be fun but that's not really a priority
because yeah I don't have to play
anything I don't want to right now I can
just kind of wing it so I've been
playing chasm which is last year's game
for like oh yeah a month it's actually
really good I wonder before we get into
it we got some dude amazing it's a quick
turnaround so good yeah last episode
wasn't it there was this 2 episode when
I kept dying in the same frickin hallway
because I had I wanted to come back for
this stupid knife that I put in
somebody's chest so I think it's funny
because it really shows what's happening
which is I'm going through all this crap
and you're just there no one's attacking
you and you're just giving me [ __ ] yeah
it's very very accurate I actually have
you can keep talking I'm looking for oh
here we go I have a shout out so so that
quote I don't know if I mention it on
knievel before but when I say that
that's from something people thought
some people thought I just made it up
and I didn't so I asked in our discord
channel if you're not a member of that
you can be it's a actually Nathan
Shepard always post a link in our
YouTube comments
so ET dragon who's been a fan of the
show since the beginning I think and she
also has some pretty awesome she also
has some pretty awesome dogs that she
sends us photos of but um so she she
recognized the quote she said she thinks
it's from It's Always Sunny that was
correct
it's from ET dragon she she talks to us
a lot on Twitter it's a professional
snake right now yeah but it's fun Frank
Reynolds starts a podcast they start a
podcast and then without telling Dee
they invite rickety cricket on to ambush
her and then he goes you're in the hot
seat it's like your favorite show after
my vocabulary yes cool well thanks fan
art in yes Sage's fan art so thank you
so much we love them so keep them coming
they're so wonderful to have yep and now
that we're done with all the wonderful
stuff let's get to the scary part so
this really sucks for me because I
completed all the medallions
which means I'm going down wait I'm not
gonna go up right now but I'm just
saying that's what we're doing this
episode yeah is bombing downtown
apologies Mike off every like
intermittently I had strep throat last
week yeah for the first time in my life
it wasn't that bad but like I mean it
can be bad but my case was not that bad
but like I still had to work from home
side of one get a bite here sick but I'm
still coughing a little bit but I'll aim
away from the mic so just so you know
just we can have a little update before
you tell me like what I should do
among caution um I have a gun and a
knife that's like pretty new to boards a
full heal some bullies not a lot you're
in good shape
people were really criticizing my board
advice there was a couple times that's
at night yeah
do that not to do it now but yeah so
okay before we forget you could do the
red book thing you don't even have to do
that yet that's you might as well
actually it's really close you could
take the red book we can go do that the
red jewel thing that we did last time
before you died
Oh didn't I do that and then I died yeah
okay but I think do I need anything to
do this
there's also according to my notes
there's gunpowder in the linen room that
we didn't have room for yeah
the linen rooms upper floor and to the
far left I think yeah
so there's way what is that was it was
the door say yeah yeah sorry the lounge
is not the linen room people people also
said that I forgot to write down there
are shotgun shells in the morgue you're
new to the show that's a very that old
actually that was Code Veronica inside
joke right
or was that yeah so which one should i
do first
yes all right yeah but alright yeah that
was up here it's here yeah the art art
room or whatever it's called I think I
might have to check the map yeah it's in
the art room yeah and I don't think
there's any zombies in here I think I've
killed them all yeah do I know the
combination to this yet no okay
yeah because you opened the other safe
and got your inventory expansion give me
that jewel and then I think you said
inspect the scepter and Inspectorate yes
sweet okay I just gonna put that back in
in your say box and actually while
you're up here you might as well just go
over to the the what sorry the lounge
actually no that's that's you got to go
through the library for that one you got
that shortcut open now what do you mean
the library the no the top door of the
lounge used to be locked but you came
from the other side and unlocked it yeah
that that was locked from the library
but you came from the long hallway with
a liquor or liquor hallway there might
be but they're easy to avoid pretty big
such a big oh the sound effects are
really good in this and they're very
loud which is like pretty scary for me
all right so take a left take a left
Oh God just working my way around here
[Music]
no zombies in here that's good
so there's gunpowder in here
yeah and that table right there anything
else no I think that should be good even
when there's nothing planned I like
don't trust anyone or anything nobody
I was Marvin doing Martin moving good
then old MacBook MacBook yeah looks like
it's like a bright white laptop should I
save just so I don't want to do this
again yeah
so I stored that is there anything else
I should bring downstairs
no do you want to have another look cuz
I'm already on caution just so you know
trying to think if you'll need the
board's you mean your ear I mean there
be Ford's in the basement yeah I'll keep
mine it's do you remember playing the
first it's not mm-hm I'll bring them if
you tell me to
no you should be good without him okay
so I got a gun a knife can you hear my
dog snoring yeah just [ __ ] C Mon what
do you have you have to first say it's
praise to Greeners or red herb No so
that's it sorry I'm looking at your save
box yeah I could grab a green herb and
heal up all the way or not uh yeah you
should
just do that men good the descent yeah
feeling good plugged up her stomach
wound with it yes right looks like it
leads underground
she's where's the lie here I'm gonna try
up
are you okay no I just go save yourself
come on it's bad we got to get you a
Holly's Clair know how this is going to
him get out of the city I thought that
was her at first
for a second here no please go she just
pushed for me
her stomach wound I don't see why she
can't help him I know just give him a
green herb she's hoarding them he's like
[ __ ] dying okay
hey Marvin
throw the hotseat Marvin thank you
[Music]
okay bye
you can't go back now you can later on
ooh okay so I need a thingy okay I got a
typewriter here case hold all my stuff
all right what's the plan Stan
you're pretty decent on ammo I would
just save the Gunpowder for now maybe
bring a either your second knife or that
flash grenade assuming it'll be close
quarters might be good to have more than
one defensive thing that's probably good
for now I think it probably almost
definitely auto saved okay I think
you're right wait a double descent yeah
this time it's the second movie
this elevator must lead underground I'm
just panicking
I'll be all right
that's what everyone says before they
die couple cones here they're really
setting the mood right now
this sucks
shake I'm gonna go in here
yeah child or something you know what
that reminds me of actually reminds me
of seven cuz remember that whole
sequence with a kid or whatever what's
that seven yeah yeah I was kind of my
least favorite part of the game yeah
what is that
[Music]
[Music]
this is super ominous nothing in here is
fun basements are never sewers are never
a good
it's totally devoid of fun though
there's a lady hey it's okay I won't
hurt you I promise
I just want to kidnap you sorry I can't
understand you
oh my god
okay first of all you have more than
enough trust me you're all right to
shoot it's I with bullets are with this
thing uh you're gonna need both but um
yeah so just art with the pistol just
wait until his eye opens and shoot it
there's also ammo lying around
how'd you turn the gameplay down after
the cutscene when do you have an option
he's very fast action sorry
I should have clarified like I think you
need to shoot him in order to hit for
him to expose the I actually I might
just keep going in circles
there it is
I got it
what if is it is it a reasonable option
to shoot him and then when his eye opens
up change guns and shoot him with a big
gun yea-ah I would actually that makes
sense to me
he's so raw might even be better off to
shoot him with the grenades first and
then like use the precision of the
pistol to shoot his eye
where the [ __ ] is he he changed
direction right here yeah it's really
rude I reload when he can oh my god I
hate this
I like doll I don't feel like I ever
have an option oh there's Sam oh behind
a camera right now
that's just like of no consequence
you're better hitting his eye you can do
it fine
[Music]
he turned around I don't think he knows
where you are right now
yes he does mate yeah I think you're
still hurting him when the eyes closed
it's just like the eye is the weak spot
there's a most rate audio in that box I
like chick
he changed [ __ ] direction where are
you listen but where are you thinking I
don't know somewhere in the mist steam
[Music]
doing that do what mr. Nate him wait
until he stops burning and then grenade
him again
based on his shrieks it sounds like it's
hurting him
oh my god yeah this thing has just
started I like just got down here like I
literally just got down here I saw this
before I saw a zombie you know yeah you
saw the little girl - Sheri
okay what's he doing is that its dick
where the [ __ ] is he
where they go go get mo while he's not
you know where would the mo - you're
right like yeah around the corner to the
right
is he dying how much do not know well
[Music]
okay
while we speak it out nope I'm freaking
out embrace the fear is he gonna die
become one with it
the [ __ ] is he I hate this I looks high
it's [ __ ]
oh my god Visine gets so read out oh my
god little girl
there I am oh [ __ ] it's unfortunate I
got hit
girls are smoking a cigarette well that
was some roll hey with that guy that
shouldn't be what are you gonna give me
I'll be your mom I think so her name her
name Claire
yeah of course I'll help you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay cool sure you get the ammo around
here first okay you said it was over
here when that guy tried to kill me yeah
I think there's a few others around the
down here oh you really did use just
like one circle at the map for that it
was worked out pretty well
is that not was there more Matt a little
bit I think I mean no you didn't do
anything wrong
I'm just saying like I found a system
and it's like this game's efficient
these games often put you not yet
there's like these games will get you
stuck right so I was like I'm just gonna
go only where I know he can't trick me
mm-hmm I choose him I can't combine
these know who a grenade what does this
do
what's this pin for it tastes funny like
a keychain
whatever happens if I swallow this whole
thing on my uh when I was doing that
clip show which was like the top ten
clips of twitch um one of them was a
girl who was like playing pub G and in
the car she was like hey guys how do I
undo a grenade how do I like undo and
like as she tried to say it second time
she blew up the whole car how do I do
this grenade put the pin back in um
alright so let me ask you this should I
come find these and then probably eat
this cuz I'm on caution
what are you sure yeah
okay
and then I'll go back to guns and I'm
gonna go up this ladder how does that
sound to you sure all right I may have a
fear when almost at the top of the
ladder when you climb up it can I you
can cheat chill wait for you just let me
get these explosives oh my goodness
Jesus which is great like usually a bad
omen though I completely agree well I
don't know something big just happened
so you should be fine for a while yeah I
just finished a boss I think I did
pretty good I only got hurt once try
pushing it you little idiot what's in
here I'm so good with kids just punches
there see you're weak you're weak and
you know it fear is the good fear is the
good stuff make sure to eat your
Wheaties and embrace your fears you're
so weak little girl
what's wrong what she think about make
sure to always get your calcium and
always put yourself in danger
what does heroin wanna do some cocaine
off my grenade launcher do I wait I
guess I do
oh yeah does that mean they got divorced
does that mean he's dead just me oh oh
does that mean I get more Wow awesome
don't be it means we've got something in
common and that's a good thing right
alright I'm gonna save I feel we're also
both divorcees I probably don't need
both of these oops right
do you agree
alright I just the visual of sherry
Burke and doing coke off Jill Clara's
grenade no I would just take this you
have three flash grenades I just
realized that they store so it doesn't
matter no I know I'm just but I don't
think you'll need the hand grenade yeah
that should be good okay
dude I can carry so much stuff right now
I hope that this little girl is
impressed with how many items I can keep
between like why can't you use her as a
inventory hold this gunpowder yeah
that's definitely what it is it worked
in BioShock Infinite Chuck me bullets
when I'm out call me Booker call me your
dad I'll be your dad little girl I'll be
your dad and your mom this is my fantasy
oh man what nothing here you're coming
up to one of your old nemesis oh sorry
sorry not Nemus that's misleading you're
some old rifles of yours you'll know
what I mean
Samoans friends yeah it's closed no [ __ ]
you little dick I should be nicer to che
she's she's trying to she seems fine
she's not like Ashley was that her name
yeah Ivanka Ivanka okay I need a card
damn it
here come up get in there Dumbo and
you're sure this is the way this is how
my mom took me last time Charlie I've
been looking everywhere for you sherry
brave little girl leave her house in the
middle of this mess on the ground hands
behind your head
you can't be serious on the ground now
Jerri
tie her hands why you - uh tup time
don't take shake don't do it Tyrone is
your gods
what's this all about child endangerment
for starters sherry
what are you gonna do to her none of
your [ __ ] business stars no she
kicked me in the tail
what's your name
what's your [ __ ] hand you come with
me now or say goodbye to my mom
absolutely how to do my job
[Music]
you [ __ ]
that was intense
yeah stay safe sherry okay okay
key card first
yeah Oh what was that noise what would
you pick up oh it look like a coin but I
don't yeah here do I have somewhere else
what's that noise
all right I'm actually not sure where I
am so I came from that guy come from the
white door no I came from the stairs the
ladder yeah so I haven't been in any of
these doors so where should I go first
one yeah okay
closest to this one oh I don't like this
was that up it's a [ __ ] liquor isn't
it no I'm not a liquor what do I do
about I'm a dog meow meow etc just go
the other way for now I'd say or kill it
with flame grenades what do you
recommend
go the other way for now I have a lock
on it
I could shoot it and it's by okay
definitely use a grenade though what do
you think oh that's your last grenade Oh
cuz I might I might run out mm yeah you
might I would just go this way for now
cuz the last one you shot took one
grenade but who knows if that's the case
with this one dude these things so rude
what the fire hydrant things
[Music]
wait why is that so scary the zombies
have guns I shouldn't say that as a joke
like resi will five and six and four
they had the worst ones also remarried
before
land of the dead zombies used guns it
was the worst one yeah it actually it
actually pissed me off yeah you gotta
iterate somehow though no you don't I
disagree
that's just something people in a
corporate weight read this word room say
bent key no longer usable but can still
open car doors and trunk with its
keyless entry buttons mm-hmm keep two
patrol car seven four three nine
did I get the key inspect that a yellow
case just like the boxes from resmio 7
oh yeah all right so seven four three
nine so now I can get into that car's
trunk or something
mr. racket howdy boys and girl this is
just like any time you see one of those
statues mr. raccoon statues you can
shoot it it's like a collectable bonus
thing and if you get them all yeah he
might be through that window the first
one actually I don't know oh that's
right you oh that actually is that the
liquor hallway that door over there
no there is the liquor hallway yeah
oh they're grenades you can go on to the
firing range okay so I need a triangle
key diamond whatever time and it's just
multiple triangles diamonds are forever
how do I get in there the other door
next to the triangle door kiss begins
with F no
oh no those guys are totally gonna wake
up we just know this don't we
wake and bake [ __ ] I know and
you know oh there's their mr. raccoon so
here's a knife that would you shoot or
knife it okay so to my left are the
grenade according to them right now
all right there what's going on it's her
hair I think oh it just looks like the
face is um like mashed down doesn't it
yeah all right so you're saying I should
knife that or can I shoot it from afar
yeah you should knife it you could shoot
it you got 46 bullets you could shoot it
but I just don't want to get near these
things honestly all right I'm getting
out of here this entire area makes me
like queasy I just don't like it oh now
that you have more names you can kill
that liquor now oh yeah
so the door here though to the left is
really close yeah that you that's not
funny Oh
you sound just like them I look just
like them to burn you burn yourself okay
okay so liquor now sure I hate this
you killed the last one in one shot
I know but they're very scary and
they're ugly and they're like naked and
their butts are on the walls yeah but
their brains are exposed okay there it
is it's still there I'm glad it's a
[ __ ] heard you I was here I'm being
quiet I [ __ ] hear it stop
sealing I think he's on the ceiling now
like yeah
like up to the right now everybody wears
this little dick
should I do it yeah
right up oh they're too
I think they're both dead no I [ __ ] up
he jumped wait you could probably use
that green herb just to be safe
he jumped yeah you should be able to
finish them off with your handgun
yeah all right another fire nice okay
that could have gone much worse what is
that
are they in the [ __ ] vents I don't
think there's gonna be more than two
right now who knows though I didn't
think there'd be more than one if you
didn't know anything you've been wrong
now a lot wrong yeah all right it looks
like there's gunpowder we're okay
Oh clickers are awful what's that oh
it's a dog you know yeah but it's a
zombie dog there's a [ __ ] zombie dog
in there isn't there
oh they're all they're all pinchers
[ __ ] its a hallway that's where they put
dogs hey what they put dogs in hallways
remember remember I told you I always
hated hallways because dog would come
from here and you have to be like shoot
shoot yeah oh my god where the [ __ ] am I
where am I going
oh actually sorry go up and inspect that
thing next to the door just so it's on
your map yeah yeah you know there's a
dog in here
[ __ ] been - oh it's a morgue
no hi [ __ ] you off knew it I saw that
[ __ ] coming
who's this rigor mortis guy deceased
kleptomaniac
maybe he's got bullets on him no I hate
when they make me do this
I hate the put that in there some
trickster can i knife them what am I
doing here they're harmless
sucks
I'm just looking for things that they
might try to scare me with about him
haha this is awful
[Music]
you go back here bury me with my flash
grenade I love like oh I would love it
if like the developers who are watching
this episode they're like dammit we
didn't even think of that is there an
item in there doesn't look like it [ __ ]
you
I have a system
yeah okay so I think might have one of
them might have had something on them
cuz the rooms still right on the map
damn it you know I think yeah the room
is red maybe when I kill them something
comes out it might just be like near
their head yeah try this guy first cuz
he wasn't like spasming
you can I few want what's that [ __ ]
noise why is the noise so awful oh
that's important
Jesus is the room green okay
can I just leave yeah they can go
through doors but yeah pretty much
whoo all right we're like crit Redfield
that's her brother nothing in this
hallway waiting for the map unless it's
dogs no like item was unless oh no
actually you know what it might be
counting the other side yeah okay
my suppose go back into the canal you
know that there's dogs in there canal
number Five's my favor
I'm too tired to actually be funny did
you ask the Super Bowl halftime show
I don't know any like maroon 5 songs
[ __ ]
hey I'm aware of them like they're hard
to avoid if you turn on a radio yeah but
I choose if not to be involved I abstain
it's not a bad idea my god is that I'm
so I'm on like such high alert right now
dude what is that [ __ ] noise
these kennels don't seem to be working
they're just all busted open all right
where am I going
so I've already I think the liquor in
this hallway I think and if that's the
case I need to take a right and leave
and go back to the parking garage
correct no no you got the diamond you
can use the oh I see what you're saying
but I could use the diamond key first if
you think yeah you probably should
there's something in this next hallway
oh there's blue orb right there we
talked about this there's a [ __ ]
liquor in this hallway and I don't have
any needs just watch Logan you can prop
might as well just combine it with the
red one yeah that's fine all right
y-you understand how I feel right now it
is
well I can't so you're on your own fear
it's on the ceiling yeah you can walk
slowly you can get by it
Did you touch it run let's run
okay I have a knife here let me ask you
this
go left go left left wait I'm in Doherty
all right where's the diamond door oh
it's in the firing range yeah you might
as well go do that you're yeah you're
gonna want it uh comment well yeah
liquors can't open doors sir what is
that okay so you're about to get another
red herb you might as well combine the
blue and red right now I know that but I
don't feel like you're listening to me
did he I heard it work
no I just can't open doors Oh does um II
probably did on the other set yes that
probably happened
the liquors canta remember there were
two zombies on the firing range there
probably that coming into this room
right now yep
now you're just panning I need you to
what am I supposed to do here
you got plenty you got three flesh your
your flash grenades are equipped you
have defensive items so you're fine
she's not gonna hurt you just get ready
to press l1 okay so you'll flash her
yeah and just wait until she gets stun
and then killer
you got five RT of your size Oh cake
like four seconds no way they're both
done well I don't have a knife it's in a
liquors body is there anything else in
this room that you didn't get the
lockers it's right over all of them it's
Nick right next to you - roll film
is that it yes yeah so I can just run
past them and leave yeah okay but
there's a liquor in this hallway yeah
because I touch touch with him uh yeah I
don't know if he would have reset or not
but like as long as you get to the
parking garage he's not gonna bother you
I think I can make it all right I'm just
gonna shadow oh oh just
[Music]
yes run just run wait what maybe uh oh I
can open up one of these cars right yeah
you so examined the key uh your
inventory yeah you gotta actually like
press the button oh that's kind of cool
I think you can get rid of the key now
this is a better gun yes I think it just
uses the same ammo um okay well should I
save I should save yeah that actually
might be if it's a actually I don't know
where they save is it's either it might
be the other Dornier yeah I think it's
the other door up top this one I think
that's in the stairwell just so you know
yeah well it's like a little tiny little
alcove
oh must be where that guy came from oh
that's an elevator oh wait is that a
door to your left
Oh raccoon monthly
oh that's cheap irons a cop this is not
a safe room I think we should find a
safe room yeah I'm a little nervous just
combine those two yeah I just feel like
I've accomplished a lot
oh yeah combine that with the grenade
launcher oh it still got two slots
combined that blue herb wood oh yeah
with the red herb I already did that I
have another red yeah just go find us
you you're pretty full I'd go find a
safe room I I'm with you so I there's
only one other door I haven't been in
yet and it's yeah and it's the one on
the other side yeah do you think there's
a safe in here this is the only other
door I haven't done wait that I'm
assuming that elevator doesn't work I
don't know uh just try the story
say broom say broom say broom ah [ __ ]
alright okay well the elevator must work
on the elevator
Oh elevator controls room that makes
sense but I think it might bring you
back up oh good obviously not I don't
know I don't know I just know that I'm
in danger like um I could combine those
gunpowder's and then take take this blue
herb or I can leave the blue web for now
those are my options uh I'd leave the
blue herb you already have one actually
you can combine those gunpowder's you
got plenty of handgun ammo well if I
combine them won't I get more hit em oh
no those are high grade Oh
so this will make what good question I
think the yellow grenades well yeah I
combined those oh well that's that's
still gonna it'll still be useful later
on but enough I'm thinking oh so if you
combine a regular one and a high-grade
that will give you grenades my bad okay
where's itself it yeah where does that
say chief's office not for general use
oh sweet so yeah that's back
how'd where am I
oh you're outside your nearest safe room
semi-closed I can't take this greener oh
yes I can I can combine it with a red
herb immediately
oh I could have combined it with the
blue I'd know the Reds better for now
you don't know if you'll need the blue
for poison or not Mary its you're more
likely to get hurt
normally them by poison I really want to
save I don't want to do this well you
have to go this way I'm just telling you
I don't want to oh thanks
I don't care but here there it is
typewriter and I say box suite what a
big office with a raccoon on the desk of
course a lot of animals so he's corrupt
of course yes
William Birkin I told you I need more
security in the Circe oh that's a sweet
little bar all right well let's save all
right
that actually is a perfect time to call
an episode oh that was you got done
pretty intense for me yeah what do you
think of the game so far uh it's great
it's extremely stressful like even when
nothing is happening I'm very stressed
out but yeah very much enjoying just the
forever tension and they're they really
get me like it's there's a lot going on
here emotionally everyone every time I'm
trying to get any item I'm freaking out
the liquors are good I thought I got
away from him but I think when he went
down I like he must have like touched my
body when you're shaking I thought I got
away with it but I didn't know it it's
tough because they always jump to the
floor when they hear anything so it's
harder to walk by him thanks everybody
for joining us we'll be back next week
happy rest of the weekend if you're not
in the discord again Nathan Shepard
always posts it in the YouTube comments
below there's a bunch of different it's
like a fan art channel there's a general
channel there's people sharing
screenshots from their current
playthroughs it's a pretty active
channel we're in it every once in a
while yeah thanks for stopping by we'll
be back on GameSpot and YouTube next
weekend should be a fun episode actually
I think every episode of this game will
be fun because it's pretty well paced
and there's always stuff going on got a
little bit of backtracking to do next
time but it's all pretty quick all right
sweet see you next week thank you guys
for joining
ah oh
I have to pee liquor I hardly know her
that's my joke